Hey hi welcome to vlog University yeah
schools back in session kids now last
week I asked you guys for some tips and
tricks on how to make better YouTube
videos but first I want to give you your
assignment for the next episode now this
one is super fun basically I'm gonna
draw a part of an image Walla and you
guys are going to go to zay Frank star
dot me to complete the rest of this
image and create a masterpiece next week
i'll pick out a bunch of my favorites
and i will put them on the show let's
get to your assignment from the last
episode which was to make a video and
tell us some tips and tricks on how to
make better videos and you guys are all
pretty much professionals you had a lot
of stuff to say but first I got a chance
to meet the one the only double rainbow
guy at VidCon and I asked him the same
thing they should open themselves up and
be honest open like nobody's watching
that's all is your friend now let's see
some of the videos that you guys
submitted hey guys today I will be
giving you advice for your videos always
make your video interesting at fund
watch just use your imagination on your
videos and just make it original riously
you need to have camera um it could be
anything i'm using an iphone if you talk
loudly it sounds better so try to
enunciate be loud make sure people can
hear you so they don't want to turn
their volume all the way to the top
which is annoying because if there's an
ad it's going to be really loud the
lining is very important and no matter
what camera you have if you have good
lighting it should turn out you know
pretty decent hold your child look in
your videos and look at the comment
section and see what people like you
take the camera hold it out about like
that then you just walk around talk to
yourself after the camera you're naughty
thanks for watching and of course always
doing your homework I can't wait to see
the drawings that you guys create for
next week and of course if you need a
link is down below to star dot me I'll
give you a direct link to the website so
that you guys can go and start drawing
like crazy I love you don't forget to
subscribe don't forget to check out the
rest of my youtube channels and of
course if you need anything else check
out my website